this is the fun hey everybody that's my
name you got that [ __ ] right okay high
four ladies and bunny ears very festive
happy Easter to all of you happy April
Fool's Day to all of you definitely a
sober move what is this like a
bachelorette party or something or you
just like we're gonna be sexy bunnies
just just Easter do you'd like do this
for every holiday what do you do on
Martin Luther King jr. - racism guys
please say hello to a very special
friend of ours Avery Pearson on the
keyboard
hey guys how are you buddy
Aries gonna be with us all night he'll
be playing some songs hope you guys are
do you like all our Easter decorations
yeah I'm happy as hell because this is
like one of the only holidays where
midgets aren't abused yeah you get a day
off yeah I get to look at other people
now and laugh at them stupid-ass
unemployed actors and bunny costumes oh
my god is this the only holiday you
don't have a costume for like commercial
auditions pretty much yeah yackin st.
Patrick's Day we just had that one that
one is the most dangerous day of the
year to be a [ __ ] dwarf let me tell
you that that's it's horrible you guys
are out drinking the beer having fun I
tried I went out to a bar and I got in a
drunk guy just looking at me going he
knows where it is
and then don't get me started on [ __ ]
Christmas that whole month can suck my
dick
you guys are shopping I go to the malls
everyone just Alma I think they
automatically assume I work there let's
walk up like you're late for your shift
you got to tell them when you had the
face thought what do you saw another oh
yeah is an elf but you weren't that was
the best so what my greatest thing ever
happened me this past holiday season I
went to a mall during Christmas and I
passed the whole Santa structure or as I
call it slave camp and know better he's
a communist where where's red never pays
his employees whatever ah that's my
theory I'm sticking to it but so I pass
it and I see this there's a dwarf yeah
rest up as an elf and I kind of smile
cuz That's not me
alright and then he looks up he makes
eye contact with me and the look of
utter and complete shame that was on his
face he was like how did you get out
Shawshank Redemption I'm on the other
side done it straight up look like one
of those Sarah McLachlan ASPCA
commercials
like like as he's looking up I just felt
like it should have been like every year
a dwarf is dressed as an elf against his
will for the price of half a cup of
coffee literally you could feed this
[ __ ] he does not eat he doesn't take
don't we don't eat that much we can live
pretty much candies that's what everyone
assumes everyone and everyone just
assumes a candy you even my damn nephew
today I got I got a nephew who's four
which means yes we're sharing clothes
and we were I want to see what that
ASPCA dwarf commercial would look like
oh sure yeah a little music we fade the
lights down a little bit are you gonna
narrate yeah
have you been to the mall recently
looking for some new shoes maybe that
scarf that the gap just came out with
have you seen this guy he forgot his
coat
every year a dwarf works at the mall
underpaid underdressed miming
[Music]
trapped inside an emotional wall
trying to get out dancing like no one's
watching
[Music]
but he knows you're watching he's
working extra hard for that dollar
please sir can I have five dollars put
it in my shoe I'll put it in my hand or
put it in my mouth I'm not picky I'll do
anything you want if you haven't cast
before just know pretty much everything
will end in a [ __ ] joke so about my
nephew
I walked into that wanting to family
friendly too quick ah wait so you had
against her with your family your nephew
was held four years old yeah and here's
the thing you're still wearing his
clothes as he started to borrow from you
yet he looks really good now okay and
I'm just looking at his Jordans like
someday they will they will be mine yeah
it's inevitable Oh the sad part is when
I like take him shopping and I'm like
hey that one with the fishes looks good
and then the clerk just assumes I'm
buying it that's depressing
but uh is this his first like big family
Easter where he's like cognizant of
what's happening yeah cuz before he was
just drooling on himself so now yeah
he's like cognizant and we got him like
there was we hired someone to be the
Easter Bunny because we're very rich
anyway and like he didn't care like he
didn't like you remember when you were a
kid when you saw the Easter but well
maybe not you're Jewish but uh like like
what you saw Santa Claus we don't have a
man wait wait wait when you saw Jon
Lovitz real the first time you saw
someone in the Jon Lovitz costume just
going yeah that's the ticket
yeah like you were full of wonder yes
you know my nephew sees the Easter Bunny
he's like nah I'm good and I think I
figured it out like his uncle is a dwarf
so he's used to having fantastical
characters in his life okay but now when
he sees a bunny he's like yeah yeah
uncle's a [ __ ] you got nothing on this
guy ah yeah you can't get better than
that he didn't do [ __ ] he looks rigs
yeah he looked for eggs he knocked over
his sister kids get holy [ __ ] you could
like I would love to see a mash-up of
like Black Friday Walmart videos and
kids hunting Easter eggs and it's the
same [ __ ] thing it's just people like
throwing elbows and like he flat out
knocked over his year and a half year
old sister and then we gotta like give
her a pep talk like well he's a dude he
feels entitled to your eggs I had no
idea where that joke was going
that's just what came out I think it
worked okay God yeah now while I was
doing Easter with my family you
literally just came here from the
airport right yeah I did a the Cherokee
Casino in West silo um Oklahoma /
Arkansas ooh that's like that's like
getting AIDS / cancer answer
yeah yeah it's it's just like it
no what's cool is it was a fun gig Laci
the gal that runs the the show was great
markets I'd never been Arkansas before
is anybody ever been
III like a one guy answer for the entire
crowd no we have not
why do we go there is there a bus
outside to take us we have we have an
Applebee's here there's no reason to go
to Arkansas yeah you get this I mean
it's a you know it's that you know you
get in your bubble so you get to see
people that you just forget are out
there you know saying you people you
forget her out there yeah you know like
when you're gambling like you know I saw
a dude with a mullet and a ponytail
mullet ponytail a Moneta Wow and and he
was wearing Ninja Turtle sweatpants and
a who's your patty st. Patrick's Day
sweatshirt so a month too late yeah wow
that's like that's like white trash with
Jerry Springer and Anna Nicole Smith all
mixed together and missing a chromosome
oh yeah I [ __ ] went there they were
uh they were a good crowd though but I
mean it's how many mullets did you see
probably 14 14 bullets you count cuz
after you see a couple you're just like
there's probably more coming my way you
know but yeah it's never been down there
I I have been Arkansas it's funny both
of my parents are from the south my
mom's from Georgia and my dad's from
Texas so when I tell people that they
just look at my height and go
I'm like no no they're not related like
I'm not what happens when cousins [ __ ]
this is not the result one may fake
accents have been breeding that's how
midgets occur but no it's a it's
actually when you [ __ ] under a rainbow
[Music]
[Laughter]
music on that it is funny how like one
thing happens in a city you've never
been to and then you kind of like base
the whole place off of war that one
interaction like after the show there's
a woman outside and she was just so
[ __ ] up like just trying to not fall
over was basically where she was at and
then and she was trying to talk about
the show and give me some feedback and
then a tampon fell out of her purse all
right which I've never come face-to-face
with that and it fell down like right in
front of me and she kind of looked down
and then I looked down and then she
looked at me and I was like oh no no
this is your move you know I'm saying
like that a tampon fell out of your
purse and then and then you heard the
Sarah McLachlan commercial as she stared
up at you and made eye contact oh my god
and then she picked it up and it was
like you know like that's definitely a
moment where it's so embarrassing like
you know the moment can like get can
become too big and like the movers
probably pick it up put it in your purse
and be like tampons am i right you know
whatever you whatever your line is to
get out of that you know you have to
have a catchphrase like tampons but
instead of doing that she picked up but
I think she was so embarrassed that like
and I wasn't giving her any overly look
of like you know oh that's great why did
you had that you know and but she must
have picked up on something because she
picked it up and then she waving it in
front of my face like some [ __ ]
tampon wizard and she was just like she
was doing this and she goes oh I can't
after tip and pound in public I was like
nobody said that what was she trying to
turn you into a woman like hey Jason
like babe the tampon back and forth yeah
oh my god so the doctor yeah for sure
okay
it's Arkansas baby and you know that's
just like I mean how many places have
you been to where you have like one
interaction and then you're like oh
that's like this place yeah well what's
amazing to me is the next time you
travel test my theory my theory is that
when you land in an airport immediately
when you get off the plane like the
first person you see in that Airport
pretty much sums up everyone in that
[ __ ] city so like every time I land
at LAX I always see a dude with scarves
always it's just always always arms and
Harper Johnny Depp combo yeah yeah and
then if you go to Arkansas I'm sure you
just see like every NASCAR stereotype
come to life oh you guys from Arkansas
all right now let's carve out your you
see it stored it's really hard to turn
left
I saw it oh I saw a lot of scale they
turned left really are they got do it
four times within one lap it's really
ridiculous I saw a lot of male overalls
male overalls
yeah that's not good like unless you're
on the farm that's not it's not a good
thing they were at the buffet and or
slot machine yeah but again [ __ ] bu
you know like they were comfy you
wouldn't wear overalls I mean I just got
out of my Oshkosh is like three weeks
ago sore subject I was wearing overalls
and I was 25 so you're uh you're Easter
was was good yeah it was good I like
doing the family thing although there
was alright there was i I do have a
racist uncle
oh yeah and he was on full force today
and so he's saying very racist things
and we go dude you're being his name's
Gordon and yeah that's a very racist
name isn't it yeah [ __ ] Gordon it just
sounds like Oh anyway so he's racist and
we and we called him out on it finally
we're like good Gordon you've been very
racist he goes I'm not racist I just
prefer certain people
I'm like that should pretty much the
definition of races yeah you should just
said the n-word have done a cartwheel
would have been less offensive the
cartwheel might offset the n-word I mean
there's only one way to find out two
three no not that was most racist so
yeah I had to deal with the racist uncle
and a a very horny dog that not a
euphemism dog was very horny and here's
the thing when you're my size and
there's a horny dog that's like a
legitimate hashtag me to situation but
I'll talk about that enough no I mean
yeah everyone's coming out with their
with their stories I haven't come out
with my story of being assaulted by
various noodles - noodle that schnauzer
poodle and yeah my leg was taken to town
so yeah not not not feeling good about
that thanks for bringing it up so that
so that was my Easter how was your
Easter well I skipped out on Easter was
that to do to do Passover all right you
[Music]
anybody else do Passover this year yeah
okay I like I like the guy with the
white hair right here no I totally
thought he was a Jew
why wait this guy no they got the white
hair and the leave the gun take the
cannoli I don't even know what that
means but it screams Jew
[Laughter]
oh it's a godfather reference thank you
I didn't get it from the puppet letters
on the front of your [ __ ] shirt you
sure you're not a member of the tribe no
Stan stand up real quick and just show
the audience what we're working with
here it would be great if we could adopt
you as a genus we don't have any we
don't have any Jews that look like you
you're circumcised yeah Devon I asked
but thanks for bringing that up I don't
know
thanks for just sharing we're top your
next question tell me about my penis
here's all the info you need for that so
what's your belief in God well the
hacked off my dick at one point it
doesn't answer our question that's got a
stake as an Asian when you find out
you're circumcised you're like dude I'm
Asian I need those inches no no the
white people are clapping he's laughing
it's okay
yeah no Passover was good you don't know
too much about Passover do I know
nothing about Passover yeah a lot of
Gentiles are pretty in the dark about it
what's the Gentile it's a non Jew not oh
[ __ ] I should know that what did it
sound like to you
I don't know just a very soft person
he's a Gentile like if dowdy could be
embodied as a person it would be Gentile
well I think III wrote a song for what I
think non-jews think Passover is oh so
yeah here we go let's sing along a few
other words probably don't wrote this
about 50 minutes ago so we go
so this is non-jews what they think
Passover is okay is that the holiday
with Jews don't eat bread is that the
holiday where Jews don't sleep in their
bed I think it's the one where they
pretend to have fun around people they
only see once a year
[Music]
they drink wine and they laugh sometimes
take a matzo bath they sing and eat some
soup then someone in the group announces
that they have HPV HPV announces that
they have HPV HPV statistically someone
here has HPV HB o that raised his head
he has HPV
everybody who has experiencing this
that's part city sigelei someone here
has HPV HPV [ __ ] more than one has
it yeah you gotta be more you at least
like two of the bunnies what bunny spa
[Music]
job he was that the species you're
representing with the ears on your head
they've they're [ __ ] not you not you
just so we're very clear not you Wow
by the way they didn't dispute that fact
so no no one stood up with like actually
now they don't have it you're wrong
they're like yeah very much I can spot
on nailed it yeah okay now so that's
what you think
Gentiles think Easter is yeah okay
or no Passover yeah so what do you think
Easter is I mean I you know you got that
rabbit involved somehow sure you guys
are looking for candy constantly sure
you're looking through lawns under
fences I think you have no problem going
into other people's houses looking for
treats no no no if the constant it's
just looking for treats for an early to
like 10:00 a.m. like the best chocolate
is before noon you know like yeah so
yeah so that's right you know well I
wrote a song about what I think Jews
think Easter is oh great okay I would
love to hear it
mine's a little happier though that was
very dark this HPV right just the facts
man mine's a little happier so let's get
a little more up being Jews Christians
believe they're full of greed so on
every Easter we all do this one deed
it's a tradition
everyone must do we take our money in
chocolate and hide it from the Jews hide
it from the Jews hide it from the Jews
we take our money and chocolate and
weight from the Jews
[Music]
I did from the Jews sir what do you hide
from the Jews
tell me put the mic in front of his face
what sir what do you hide from the Jews
[Music]
he's not answering that question you
want he wants to say money anyway so
that's what you think of these great
guys every in the spirit of Easter I
think it's only fair that we that we
bring out somebody who is you know
embodies this holiday yeah more than
anyone ladies and gentlemen okay ladies
gentlemen please welcome to stage one of
our very special guest tonight you know
from his Comedy Central show the Jim
Jeffrey show ladies gentlemen
[Applause]
those watching this show you meant to
bring the Easter Bunny etiquette Allah
had 20 minutes before anyone okay I just
saw you so I figure like you had to go I
wasn't like trying to get on I was
trying to watch the shows I kind of hear
it backstage
oh I said I'd like to talk about all the
things are hard from the Jews
what do you hide the Easter season Jim
HPV come on one can t put he's [ __ ]
Hannah you've had sex with more than
zero people have HPV hey I talked to
Drew our friend dr. Drew's yes right now
you
I said because you have that you didn't
even to our hard when the Jews I'm not
not much anymore there was a famous I
have to keep those things hidden away
from the hidden I am I my son actually
when you talk about money in exile yeah
my son they had an Easter egg hunt at
the school and my son got the egg that
had 5 bucks in it ok switch people
school which people yeah yeah my bucks
oh my cyan't my samples at this agency
dad I got the egg with five dollars in
it I said that's good Hank all you need
to do is get a hundred thousand more of
those to pay for your education my
school with like famous people's kids oh
yeah alright we're watching we're
watching Wonder Woman
remember the kids now but watching
Wonder Woman and my son guys
oh that's Sarah's mom what exactly I'm
right why why no I'm gonna Sarah's mom
I mean you're [ __ ] kidding me your
kid goes to school with gal gadot yeah
Gavin yeah skids I said my son gets
along with every kidneys [ __ ] class
yeah except for [ __ ] Sarah ah
and and I say today my god what's wrong
with her he goes don't like her and I
guess she seems like a nice girl guys
what are you kid okay cuz I want to go
to her birthday it's like I just I just
hang around the cop I can school there
waiting for PAL good doctor come out and
I'm like I'm not with the mother anymore
sure you're happy wait what what sort of
things does he say that like what his
reasons that she sucks as a kid I don't
know I don't know yeah tell you one
other thing right so what happens with
these private schools they try to get
you to do gigs right that's a big thing
for us gotta raise money for the school
yeah raise money well do a fundraiser
and you go isn't the 40 grand I'll give
you a year every day isn't that the
fundraising no a gym no fundraise by
going to work and giving you 40 [ __ ]
grand are you 2 grand short right and
then they're like can you help out at
the school and I'm like could I could
just give you 5 grand and you this phone
conversation gonna be over well they
just say they went to me they go they go
can you can you perform at our
fundraiser and I said look I gotta I
gotta hang out with the other parents
I'm not too keen on performing in front
of the other parents so I have to write
a Christmas show and what oh jeez yeah
and then then the teacher goes to me she
goes well you'd only be the opening act
and then I went alright [ __ ] games on
right yeah no one calls Jim [ __ ]
Jeffries the opening [ __ ] and a half and
so I wait or who he got closing and they
went Daft Punk
anyways I did it I was good I was sure
like one of the concert without the
helmets right helmets holding my kid
goes to school with a member of DAF Punk
but I don't know who it is
every dad I look at like I reckon that's
DAF by if we kid if a parent has a
slightly European accent like that'd be
[ __ ] DAF I've always thought about
Daft Punk like they have the perfect gig
because they put helmets on so they
don't even have to be there well in
theory but you can't pick up a lot if
you're helmetless
no no what no one can tell a person just
by their body sorry Brad of course yeah
I could never pull that move off like oh
it's not Brad Williams no no it's
totally now every tell the story about
my son gave you the balloon oh no well
basically I was at I was at your house I
was that my he was at my house yes I was
about two at the time and I think was my
birthday or something like that and so
we had a birthday party but because my
the reason we had a birthday party was
because my son was like you have to have
a birthday party in my sons my birthday
parties involved cake and balloons yeah
Chris my mind for the last twenty years
it's been cocaine and loneliness just me
just me I'm married now inside my son it
was about to have his first dwarf
experience which is a beautiful moment
in any child's life yeah I remember mine
it was when I walked in front of a
mirror and said what the [ __ ]
you got to imagine what your mother's
first dwarf apparently they've called a
tan up vagina and recrawl my god that
was the first one I tore up it's my mom
why are you doing that yeah you know you
don't know do you Craig you Padma count
continues do you Hank for breads arrival
what's it I know I didn't say there's
gonna be a weird-looking person I just
said some of my friends are showing up
yeah yeah and say so Hank walks up and
he sees Brad everyone in the party
tensed up like I [ __ ] here we go and so
I used to make these two other Tommy yes
he staged up and down and then he walked
away and I turned to Brad and I said I'm
sorry Brad I I did I don't I didn't know
what was gonna happen then bedsit it's
all right that happens all the time yeah
hey anyway about two minutes later my
son comes back and he he gives Brad a
balloon yeah because he thought even
[ __ ] kids drinks there's no drinks
backstage this this is the dressing room
where where which oh yeah
this is the dressing room where Richard
Price did coke with Robin Williams and
you I walk backstage and I said look
I've dropped my kid off Easter's over
there's any drinks and you went we have
water well because we don't make too
much money I hear on the about last
night podcast how many stores making
money they can afford
this place hasn't gone under for many
years I'm sure it's Pauly Shore still
alive is he still running the place
what's going on tell me something and
say weasel well when you said his name
twice if you say it one more time he
does appear I'm just glad that your kid
had that reaction because I've got a lot
of reactions from kids when they see me
for the first time I remember quite -
you become a dad that's oh oh [ __ ] and
then I go to school everyone's like whoa
but is that kid on the weirdest thing
about you becoming it dad yeah I'm gonna
be the kid seeing you first it's just
that the kid's gonna be black anyway
most kids are very confused when they
see me because a car one time and the
kids just called me here oh yes it's on
yeah it's uncommon a central allegedly
[Applause]
kids how you arms only cut your feet oh
no it's fine it's just uh get out of my
car one time and a kid saw me drive I
know it takes a lot of phone books but I
can [ __ ] do it why do you need the
phone book just burn books no not the
phone no person who can drive for you to
call them yeah exactly I got in the car
and [ __ ] use them from my rotary
phone and aggressive are reference and
be [ __ ] some eight people got that
reference I love it that's why did you
have worked
sorry system strapped to your foot and I
pumped up my Reebok Pump shoes and then
no I got out of my car and a kid saw me
out of the car and look and look this
dad and why does that kid get a car
still some laughs with that buildup did
you answer it correctly yeah affirmative
action no but your show just came back
it's too weird we are every Tuesday we
record every Tuesday so I meant to be
learning the script tomorrow how was the
like how do you approach season two I'll
tell you what happened with season two
on a Tuesday and we didn't do as good as
Roseanne who was against us in our time
so it was Roseanne and it turns out that
that show did better than we did
laughing [ __ ] you I'm still a guy with
my own TV show don't hit the skids isn't
he this is like after two all over again
now the guy could Dudley Moore Dudley
Moore played a guy good happened near
Dudley Moore got Parkinson's he got the
same rare form of Parkinson's that
Richard Pryor got and Michael J Fox God
who were all renowned coke heads back in
the day you can't do family ties and
back to the future at the same time
without cocaine he was filming one a
night you can't you can't do it hey so
all three of them got these very all
these three cokehead entertainers that
is very rare form of Parkinson's that no
one in science can figure out what
happened Oh Chinese that's the fact
since I'm gonna get
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Asya tell me more towards the end just
he was it was concert pain as good as a
pianist right and he used to do shows
where he's playing piano and then
halfway through the show he'd get old
jittery and they go oh if I can dumb
these drunk again nice little
Parkinson's up is that a term I Parsons
up t-shirts there in the there in the
logos a bit shaky hey I say is there any
way more on Ferguson's sure I say you to
charge the Parkinson's yeah you got your
Parkinson's where you had a lot of fun
you got your Muhammad Ali their
magazines yeah he's just sick facts
people way you just got it yeah because
you sin too much sure sure well this is
a Christian holiday so it's only
appropriate that we say that is good you
got the whole thing with the FL they go
we found out that the NFL players become
like mentally challenged later on in
their lives and we can't figure it out
really I've gotta guess that movie with
Will Smith 3 came in as the doctor he's
like I've been doing some research it's
a pretty good Will Smith you guys I've
done a bit of research hmm find out if
you keep hitting your head into things
not good no I thought keep bashing your
head into things eventually you won't be
as smartest people who don't bash their
head anything every can you button that
moment with something grating that your
job is the keyboard player at a podcast
are you married a Mary do you have a I'm
Mara never Kenya you have a kid so we
look at your child good dude you forget
y'all and go daddy plays people yeah
podcast
yeah this all right this guy his kid
already has CTV
I'm not proud of my life you know what
are some of the segments that people can
look forward to that you guys I heard
you talking about one thing you went to
the red-light district and met the
oldest prostitute the oldest prostitutes
in the world there were twins mm-hmm in
in in Holland yeah are called the [ __ ]
[ __ ] with their last name is their
name is [ __ ] they're the [ __ ] twins
that sounds like something Liam Neeson
would say like release the pocket
the [ __ ] twins and they're in their
eighties and there were two oldest
prostitutes in the world and they still
work one of the hands is athletically
shaped around a [ __ ] she says a
permanent like a [ __ ] I'm all for
legalized prostitution I'm back to talk
about that in the next episode actually
I'll grab the next episode because the
whole thing that Amy Schumer and lose
that God does late night show all of
them the foreign one anyway anyway
there's a new any trafficking bill
that's going on and look I agree there
shouldn't be human trafficking we live
in LA we all we hate all traffic well
what happens is when you eliminate this
bill where girls can advertise on web
pages like back page and Craigslist what
happens is the the actual murder rate of
women has gone up 14% so what what what
happens is you go to countries like
Amsterdam and Australia where
prostitution has been legal and you'll
find things that happen like this
there's been a five percent drop in
divorce crime drops STDs drop everything
drops there is no downside the legalized
prostitution you can't stop it it's the
oldest profession in the world right
it's older than the [ __ ] war on
[ __ ] drugs you can't fly gonna stop
it right so where am i heading oh I
meant the [ __ ] twist so so what I was
I made the [ __ ] two twin sisters
Jerez and one of their names is Lucy and
she actually introduced me to her as
Luce [ __ ]
like yeah the oldest prostitute in the
world's name is loose [ __ ] and I
laughed and I said that's funny
your name is loose [ __ ] and she didn't
see why that was funny at all 80
something years on the planet she hasn't
had a single tourist go come on that's
an easy thing to laugh at yeah
your name's loose [ __ ] now is that
just like a prostitute's nod that was
they know the showers just in Holland
yeah lookin for loose [ __ ] no way
that's a feel piece for doing we're
doing another field piece on on the
circumcision and we're doing oh you'll
like that circumcise a circumcised
gentleman right here you're Jewish and
your agent and you mean oh oh he's
trying to get into all the heavy you
didn't have anything to lose my friend
I'm circumcised as well we can't talk
anymore
don't Google that Google or Google and
[ __ ] it okay good that's it brings up I
have a Netflix special coming out in
June right doc and I talked about
talking for 15 minutes in my news 15
what what pornhub rabbit hole which is a
category in itself you go down to get
doing a thing about how in sign language
and this wasn't great for podcast baby
but in sign language this means gay men
to to pointer fingers together fingers
to go yeah lesbians two holes Brinegar
that makes sense yes sir it's like the
death don't know what's going on
[Laughter]
it's like the Deaf thing this is what
guys get up to yeah never lights a bash
sticks together yeah and I was doing no
luck until you try it routine I was
doing the routine and a garli I was in
New Zealand the guy in the audience with
that's docking
I said what's docking and then he just
laughed and stopped talking and then I
googled docking isn't that a waste of
four hours when is it what is a special
come out ah June it's a weird thing when
that because of that it's like they're
about to announce a date but I'm not
allowed to say it because the world will
blow up but it's it's June sometime
unless I get caught in the me to
movement and then it never happens
fingers crossed
[Laughter]
Jim you aren't you are here on a holiday
and we do want you out here if I'm not
going anyway okay it needs to be another
chair for Adam Devine yeah we got a beer
or as I call him paji Matt Damon yeah
guys one more time for Jim Jefferies
[Applause]
Easter would not be appropriate with
that ladies and gentlemen the Easter
Bunny
[Music]
[Applause]
this is actually working out better than
they thought oh yeah what was the end
result in the fact that you can't do up
the back here out there this is this is
what drinking at three o'clock the
boarding trying to cope with podcast
ideas gets you this is what happens when
you do a podcast and you have friends so
yeah I couldn't do this podcast and have
a guide you just gotta have enough
friends to get one plant to go are you
wearing ill-fitting outfit and jump
around easily buddy come sit down and
join us
yeah yeah the these are not eggs from
Jim's kids private school they don't
have $5.00 okay you don't have to fight
over these eggs alright great job guys
there's your money boy first time ever
on a podcast yeah you must be tired
you've had a tough day oh it's a long
one sorry
I'm gonna assume that your father's the
Cowardly Lion from the way what did you
do today Easter Bunny how was your
Easter underwhelming oh sorry sad to
hear what not a great day for the old
Easter Bunny why is that what happened
well you see my wife I got home from all
my Easter work excited to see her and
celebrate Easter yeah but I found her
were three of my friends
oh [ __ ] hey she [ __ ] like rabbits
which friends Roger
Greg hey so funny
Rogers a euphemism for [ __ ] in prison
great who's ever I Greg the [ __ ] out of
it go is it really yeah I Roger the
chick is determine what the rod that's a
real thing it's a Roger someone doesn't
have any reference to Roger Rabbit
because it would be awesome yeah no no
Roger to go yeah I Roger the [ __ ] so
when you can you win nice that Desert
Bunny's got one more friend whose and
you cut him off yeah who's your who's
your final place tell us more oh honey
you brought it back
he Lenny Bruce you you see buddy how
long have you been working as the Easter
Bunny well you see Adam for all of time
and have you liked the job the whole
time until today yeah you've been doing
this for the all of time and I still say
you haven't aged well
well that's on account of all the
drinking you can drink on the job
I sure can wine I sure do where do you
how early do you get to the houses to
hide all the eggs that's for me to know
and the police do never find out there's
a quick question water-rich kids get
good quality chocolate and poor kids get
[ __ ] each other why do you do that it
seems very hurtful we all have what
we're supposed to
[Applause]
[Music]
and you think this bit would work Easter
Bunny way so during the Holocaust art
all me that's a fact yeah you know [ __ ]
off my to him circumcised I to him yeah
now happy Yoda Easter Bunny uh do you
ever kind of do you ever eat all the
chocolate before you deliver it to the
kids I have diabetes do you have your
insulin dependent yes in fact I am I'm
gonna have to take a break here to go
shoot up insulin
why do you what do you answer every
question like you're hosting a game show
from 1977 this is just how my dad was
it's learned Betty seems like he was
born with a stroke
a hop skip in a stroke
[Applause]
[Music]
you wanna stick around he's gonna stick
around Easter Bunny in my life okay you
know [ __ ] going anyway go sit on the
steps I don't give a [ __ ] if Adam Devine
as to stand bunny with me constantly
there you go you got him there buddy
Brad Brad scoot down oh yeah it's gonna
be maybe me and you versus the world so
an atom comes up here and he tries to
say funny things we were about them you
will say humorous things like he
actually has HPV our next guest you guys
know from workaholics pitch perfect
their new movie game over man just
dropped on Netflix ladies and gentlemen
the one the only
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you my friend good all you
degenerates you guys decided to spend
Easter in the [ __ ] Satan's nutsack
yeah we're all doing it we're all very
lonely people here but we all came
together Adam have you met the Easter
Bunny before I know I met him backstage
oh good oh you shut up together we shut
up together it's funny or the second
time was that I said we showed up
together is a funny thing they're saying
these you guys have a nice interview
I feel bad about calling you chubby Matt
Damon I'd like to apologize in front of
every thought that your child everything
I think you're a regular Matt Damon and
you've always been very sweet to me
thank you
touch dicks touch dig ZocDoc
stop enemy is circumcised yeah oh we
can't do it ah son of a [ __ ] we can't
do it the problem is if we if we try to
pull that dicks I'll just become like a
Chinese finger trap you kind of do yeah
you kind of really touch upon this but
you actually you actually showed your
dick you showed your dick in the movie
yeah yeah who seen game over man just
drive uh mouth [ __ ] the rest to you
now did you hesitate at all to show your
penis in a movie you've got to see this
thing no I did well we wrote the movie
like six years ago so I've been prepping
way to next year those dick exercises
you can do that's dick Nichols like he
goes for your dick Don nickles no it
wasn't it was a weird it was more weird
for the like crew guys that it was like
the second week of shoot in the movies
so they didn't know us or you know how
we were and then for just like grown men
my dad's age should just be staring at
my dick through a camera now art dude do
you try to like shove it up a little bit
before you do the shot Jesus Brad yeah
admittedly the first few takes are like
yeah we shot this scene for like eight
hours so by you know you're not gonna
keep a half-chub for eight hours now oh
not with that attitude unless you have
extends were you happy with the shot
they used Brad you gotta watch it man
there's lots of shops now I really just
focus on this one moment of the movie
I'm really not get half of this your uh
your folks that was the I mean they'd
seen it before but that was the first
time they've seen my dick before Yeah
right yeah did you have any weird like
friends from high school or people
reaching out sending you messages about
it I got 100% comments from like my dude
friends because they go girls it's
really it's a it's a feminist movie yeah
sure
because
there's no female nudity it's all dicks
all the time just like three ladies
weirdly the ladies didn't appreciate it
the guys are the ones who really reached
out we're like damn dick that's what we
think I'm the pilots Australian that
ever lived right my dick is my darkest
bit of skin yeah and it's my only bit of
skin that's never seen the Sun like it
is more tan than the rest of my body
yeah mine's definitely four shades
darker okay so we get together we can do
a movie called eight shades he's our
buddy Jade's of tape Easter why'd you
have a title for them I was just gonna
say my dick stays inside my body all the
time you should have given that advice
to louis c.k
oh I'm sorry no no actually gonna stop
talking about how Aziz Ansari had a bad
date
Jim Adam and I just went to our Zapata
plant the potted plant where's it oh
yeah that he jerked off because he
jerked off can I have a [ __ ] drink
man I don't want to interview he's from
Incubus I loved your song The Black
Parade why is there a [ __ ] lime how
much is the bartender hate you all right
put the line back in I just went on tour
with Adam over to Australia and Japan
Jim how when you would people go Danny's
back when how many people that go to
Australia that you know come back with
like I fed kangaroo and held koala
stories and do you get every pijl I know
that they have I [ __ ] a kangaroo yes
when I told people I was going to
Australia on this tour like every one of
my friends were like you know koalas
have chlamydia why do all my friends
join chlamydia but you know the Koala is
actually the lady said I'm on earth
people think it's a sloth you know the
sloths only sleeps for 18 hours a day
which is rubbish because the Koala rocks
it out at 22
and still as cute as the Koala sloth can
go suck a dick very slowly in between
naps I'm just sticking up for a nice
thing ever cause I'm still involved in
this to be honest Lea because we said
Australia and then you just hopped right
in back I [ __ ] the first koala with
chlamydia didn't have familia till I
[ __ ] he was originally a brown rabbit
that's his chlamydia infection kai
Gary's body is it itchy I didn't know
that chlamydia was itchy I'm gonna need
a beer now to keep up with Jim so will
you tell people about your USO tour
experience I went on the USO tour
experience what is this a podcast I went
I went on the USO tour over Christmas
and we went to Iraq and Afghanistan and
[ __ ] and give it up that's where you
cheer I've done four trips but anyway
I really did you got with general dumper
no I waiting the middle of the [ __ ]
night I went back in 2006 when the war
was happening victory over you we're
still at war
currently they're still over there both
your dicks are you oh yeah you tell me
who is this general dumper guy you were
mentioning he's like he's the head of
our military and we went on the tour
with him and he's like the the number
one guy he's the main general general
Dunford he's a [ __ ] badass and but he
would sit on the side of the stage while
you performed which is [ __ ]
terrifying yeah because he's the general
and he told me he was like hey don't
talk about your dick don't what you I'd
be screwed yes I love to talk about yeah
don't talk about your dick don't make
fun of me and don't curse and so I
didn't until the last show and then I
talked about my dad cursed him in front
of him and then afterwards I go and like
the little green room area and he's back
there and he goes I didn't like that and
I go well that's why I waited for the
last show and he goes I can respect that
[Laughter]
so my dad took my dad with me yeah and
he got my dad was like so [ __ ] pom
tattoo you have are you just emptying
the bar in front of Jim
wait here I don't have one
Easter what do you need a drink it's
good that you still have a dad my dad
died years ago okay I hope your dad's
here never win - he was a carpenter like
Jesus only your dad was real that's a
hurtful thing to say because I shouldn't
your dad came from the Shire yeah people
yelling accent but so you brought your
dad from Omaha Nebraska Aryan Midwest
father Australia no I took my dad from
Omaha and he came with us and he got he
was like he kept telling me how he's not
gonna get [ __ ] up on this trip which
is what you say that you are you're
planning on getting really [ __ ] up
yeah sure so the first night we we had a
show in Spain and it went great and then
afterwards went okay and afterwards I'm
not gonna lie to you people not on this
holy day and we have like a little party
afterwards and my dad gets [ __ ]
wasted and it keeps going I'm all gonna
have one more and then I cut to him and
then the night holding a bunch of
Marines going [ __ ] Isis am i right
and the next morning I'm like we have to
knock on each other's doors because you
were leaving at 6:00 a.m. or you know
we're drinking we're partying so he
didn't knock on my door it's like 558 in
the morning and the woman the USO
woman's like don't be later than the
general general Dunford we'll leave your
ass and we're like okay and so I'm
knocking on my dad's door the woman
comes up she's like the generals in the
lobby sang in a hotel lobby when I was
at a base was just a [ __ ] courtyard a
dirt that we had to meet in we you seem
to be staying in some place with a lobby
yeah we're gonna fight Isis we're still
kicking on in the lobby doesn't have
that filtered water where they put
watermelon in you should blow it man so
after the spy you're in a love it so I'm
not gonna out of my dad's door and she's
freaking out you had jewels there
and not get on the knock around the door
my dad opens he's wearing the exact same
clothes that he wore from the night
before and I'm like we gotta go the
generals in the lobby and he goes okay
and then he pulls his pants and
underwear down yeah and I'm just seeing
my dad's dick first thing in the morning
which is a terrifying thing to see and
then he and I'm like what are you doing
we got to go and then he just curls up
in the in a blanket and goes just leave
me and then I smack him in the face I'm
like the generals in the [ __ ] lobby
I'm not leaving you in Spain we got to
go and then he goes oh you should have
told me and then puts his clothes on and
we leave but he leaves his prescription
glasses in Spain so now he's blind for
the rest of the trip so he can tell you
Matt Damon Wayans so during that one
Easter Bunny did you hear can you
translate I need a translator I'm sorry
I'm sorry
so you dad left his glasses so he
couldn't see yeah he couldn't see he was
[ __ ] blind for the rest of this trip
and I couldn't see anything but I found
his prescription sunglasses in the bag
so he rocked these [ __ ] prescription
sunglasses for like six days like during
the day while the war was happening
actually the face we're on in Iraq was
an Isis base just six months prior okay
you hear that people we want about 12
inspires is run by the Taliban but you
wouldn't know about it it'd be the dead
rules yeah that this what fatherhood
looks like ladies and gentlemen I can't
wait Teletubbies anyway do you have any
every doesn't have a new baby you have
any fatherly advice yeah yeah one year
old in the piano guys that's the Easter
Bunny we could just say Adam oh you
three people okay Avery's a new dad
who's he behind you I'm a big fan and
that wouldn't be bullied in Australia
Yeah right Nicholas
[Music]
how do I be a better dad Jim please Jim
[Applause]
show you how to be cut off his story was
that story this oriented right long gone
my friend the story where your dad loved
you
yeah and then you got more than you do
debt you did love you use it rock
acceptance no that wasn't the story at
all weren't even listening to the
[ __ ] story anyway I think we can all
agree if you give love you get love ya
[Music]
well ladies and gentlemen it is art
stuff this boy in this book guys until I
say everything I want to say about this
yeah that's fine anyway so Jeff gets
everything off his chest everyone okay
what about marks yeah this is Jim
special
we're gonna watch every scoops for one
for one yes do you think you're bigger
than me that's Uncle Mike he died he was
an alcoholic you know uncle died he died
in a or my grandmother's bathroom
awesome yeah that's it okay his heart
exploded so he was an alcoholic so I
think heroin yeah that's my family
they're like no he's an alcoholic
[Music]
he was a skinny alcohol I just I just
keep waiting I don't know when I drink
my Irish face gets fat as [ __ ] he was a
gaunt [ __ ] I just keep waiting
for you say you brought a lot of sad
understate you felt the need to do it
it's a warning for you Jim someone who's
gonna become your uncle this is not a
podcast Jim it's actually an
intervention we all love you Barry well
love you want you to live by the
keyboard
do you [ __ ] know you don't even put
in the case don't you do that with
publicani and see if you wanted even
evany in our brain
yeah yeah we were only protecting I
think a part
play something only talk
[Music]
if you play every library I don't know
evany I was born after the hoes me you
don't look like it we Jam do they have
April Fool's Day in Australia no we just
have the genocide of the aboriginals to
chase that one responsible wait so what
do you I mean with you what do you think
of the day you think it's [ __ ] or as
a comedian how do you view April Fool's
what have you April Fool's it was a good
easy question yeah had a bad question
Adam do pranks
what did you do what did you do well you
know Brad he was told wait I'm not this
is my regular door I'm so mad I bought a
ticket for Six Flags Magic Mountain
tomorrow this is not gonna work
[ __ ] Adam just got a dollhouse for you
and you're like wait a minute that was
too far that's too far we can always you
think they're [ __ ] Brad's dying Bobby
never Bobby's out of each [ __ ] leg I
don't even know how to respond and she's
a nurse yes Bobby Bobby okay yeah Kate
actually looks like Adam some life-sized
Barbie on here right now I'll [ __ ] it
just to prove a point
great cool I'm fat Matt Damon and I look
like Ken you got a C game over man all
four and 1/2 inches yeah flop it around
your swaps thank you very much
does your dick flop with a water on the
side where it just Mike makes a
ring-a-ding-ding you miss the beginning
he's the only one who announced it out
of everyone
well we bring up we bring up April
Fool's because most comedians hate April
Fool's for the same reason why most
drunks hate st. Patrick's Day it's just
kind of amateur day and everyone just
kind of like things are gonna do a joke
and by the way if you do the whole oh
I'm pregnant
April Fool's or you like fake a death
you're not funny you're a [ __ ]
sociopath all right did anybody do
anything for April Fool's today like do
any sort of elaborate prank or any good
ones I tell my kid it was Christmas
doesn't love you he wasn't loved enough
that's why I didn't get presents I'm
gonna bait him and then this is her
April Fool's
[Laughter]
Adam have you ever done any April Fools
pranks I used to work at another comedy
club not mentioned The Improv yeah I
called there
I called next door does like the Booker
and I called Rita the manager and I said
that it was on fire did she believe you
yeah the fire truck came was she there
no she was at home and then Mack home
and the old Booker that used to book all
the improv he came running over with a
fire extinguisher like where is it and
I'm like it's back there it's in its
further it's not that big when it gets
hot you'll know that it's this part that
looks like fire well I cut a lot of
trouble I got ready sure stop trying to
wrap this up oh no this is like the
people are [ __ ] loving this you're
there no I gave you a special champagne
glass of [ __ ] it's good Adams talking
about places that he tried to burnt down
and you're trying to stop the fun
continue the fun these people have
nowhere to go
this is true this is this is a real
people without children without love
their choice to spend their race to run
[Music]
they went through a lighter on the stage
that don't carry only that close Egret
we got like go forever this could be our
whole life
I would like nothing more this could be
like the worst episode of modern family
ever yeah you showed up you broke up
with that girl then you're hanging out
with a dwarf and whatever his name is
[Laughter]
[Music]
Brad reader read none of these stories
well yeah cuz I was I was bringing up
because we're talking about sort of bad
April Fools pranks no I'm gonna okay so
like a regular person
oh I will clap a little right this will
make people to accept you in society now
we're all wrote comics have has AMA
biscuit walk that right quicker than
others only takes nine of my stamps that
match every one of yours it's cool I
don't know if you guys have been to
Kansas City there's a very popular radio
DJ there named Johnny - Johnny yeah
Johnny there so he actually got in
trouble for a bad a bad April Fool's
prank he wouldn't he went on his show
and he said that don't drink the water
because because the water has been
poisoned with hydrogen dioxide smart
people are laughing okay that's the
scientific name for water so people
believed it called in threats and called
yeah and the mayor had to say had to
address it as a terrorist attack so yeah
that happened to our buddy Johnny there
so uh all I'm saying is choose your
April Fools pranks wisely people hire
Naboo Fool's Day
I dieted ago they had a child with a mm
[Music]
you should have seen the look on her
face with the baby like I tell it goes
to the room that I'm single Easter Bunny
do you have any April Fool's experiences
or pranks that you've been a part of or
maybe my wife sleeping with all my
friends was an April Fool's joke
[Music]
talk about it
you're right I never I never used my
insulin sir I'm gonna have to get one of
my ears amputated do you want to just
want to talk about it or sing about it
[Music]
could you start over
[Laughter]
you know one on waste produced a story
tell me
listen graciously to Soho
[Music]
[Laughter]
No
[Music]
if living is without you I'm gonna try
jay-z I bet seems like a good level I
[Music]
think that's how we're gonna it and
that's how you get three wishes ladies
[Applause]
thank you very much for coming out
tonight you have a good time what number
do you remember Adam Devine Easter Bunny
Sammy danto
ladies and gentlemen give it up for my
heterosexual life mate mr. Adam ray
[Music]
one more time for Brad Williams giving
up the Red Wings and every bearded on
the keyboard
subscribe me about last night podcast
thank you guys very much we'll see you
next time Happy Easter
and not everybody
[Music]
there's no rules
slow down
[Music]
you